Isis claims responsibility for a massive
bomb in Baghdad that killed 17 people
surveillance video captured the moment
of the blast outside a popular ice cream
shop the bomb in a parked car was set
off by remote control 32 people were
injured here a new car bomb this morning
exploded near a government office in
Baghdad and that blast killed 14 people
the stepped-up attacks come as us back
to rocky forces battle for the last
areas of Mosul under Isis control
Charlie d'Agata has been near the
frontlines
he is now in Erbil Iraq and joins us
Charlie good morning good morning to you
Gail what we've seen in the fight for
the old city is simply guerrilla warfare
at its very worst in each day that it
goes on becomes more dangerous for those
trapped inside Iraqis security video
shows what this battlefield has now
become dense urban terrain close quarter
combat wage the rooftops as troops inch
forward they're capturing more than
ground they showed us what looked like a
sales lot for Isis car bombs
armor-plated tractors SUVs reinforced
with steel only in the front to protect
suicide bombers from being shot dead
before reaching their targets they're
the most dreaded Isis weapon on the
battlefield
and just one danger facing a UN
estimated 200,000 residents effectively
held prisoner inside the old city
leveling whole neighborhoods with US
airstrikes and artillery isn't an option
at a frontline command center Staff
General Jafar Elbe taught and his men
observe a drone camera pinpointing a
suspected Isis position some of the name
they're hiding among the residents and
preventing them from fleeing he said a
civilian population is the biggest
obstacle slowing down our forces the
Iraqi military has urged residents to
leave but militants of booby-trapped
homes with bombs and snipers have opened
fire on anybody daring to make a run for
it to Isis they're simply a massive
human shields far too valuable to give
up easily now normally what we see in
Mosul is once these neighborhoods are
liberated the residents come rushing out
but we just haven't seen that mass
exodus at this point there doesn't seem
to be any escape Charlie Charlie d'Agata
in northern Iraq thanks